hi everyone alex gent here so in today's
video i'm going to be showing you what i
think is the most important movement
for both club swinging and staff
spinning
make sure you stick around to the end of
the video because i'll also be showing
some martial applications of this
movement
okay so let's get
so when we start i'm going to be
starting off with the clubs and
if you think of when we're using the
staff if you think of the side that's
the thumb side if you like is
representative of where the club would
be
so as i show you the movement i'll
explain what i mean okay to start with
i'm going to be showing you the movement
with the club
um from side to side
i'm just going to be just doing a basic
pendulum
so it's swinging across my body at
shoulder level
both sides i'm changing this to the
other hand
so the changeover is going to be in the
middle it comes up the club's facing
towards
my head i change hands here
and i let it slide out to the side and
again i pendulum on the other side as
well
okay again shoulder level
so let's do the same with the staff
so same movement with the staff pendulum
from side to side
we're going to do the hand change over
in the middle so
unchangeover as i said imagine this is
the club side
so the thumb side that's where the pub
is so you'll be changing over at this
point
and then taking it into the other hand
and then you can pendulum
on the other side as well
we can then go backwards and forwards
from side to side so we'll go just from
side to side and your room
making sure it's shoulder level from
side to side
make sure with this side the the back
side of the
staff is behind your arm
so it's behind your arm rather than
in front of your arms
okay and we're just going side to side
you can do this both with a pull or a
step
so this next part of the movement i'm
bringing the club up at 45 degree
angle so it's kind of kind of coming in
towards my head
it's as if you're going to hit yourself
on the head but you don't and you just
rest it on your shoulder
okay when you're first learning this
movement you might just want to rest it
here
as it makes it easier when you turn your
body 180 degrees and then throw it out
to the other side
and then you connect that to your body
movement so when it's resting here you
turn your whole body
around face the opposite way and
throw the club out you then let it
pendulum across
and then you bring it back up again okay
so you turn your body
throw it out and you're on the cross
bring it back up okay and you just carry
that movement
going until you can then do it all in
one
when it comes up you want to let it drop
down
when you're doing it in a fluid movement
you let it drop
let the weight feel that weight of the
club
swing around and then cast out to the
opposite side
so as it comes up
you want to avoid doing something like
this because this is a different
movement
or anything where you're pulling it like
this again that's a different movement
nothing wrong with it but it's just
different to what i'm showing you here
you want to make sure that it's coming
in towards you turn your body
throw it out okay so
then when you change the direction
you essentially bring it across your
body this time
and you're at this 45 degree angle turn
your body
and then throw it out this way so we're
casting it away so rather than before
we're going
inwards this time we're going outwards
okay essentially this is just a reverse
of the other direction
45 degrees by five
cast it out okay
so then now at this point we're in this
position where it's coming across i can
actually
change it to my other side and then do
the same on the other side
we're back to the beginning where i stop
here 45 degree angle
throw it out bring it back around
there okay and i'll just repeat the same
process on this side
both directions inwards and outwards
45 cast it out
okay then we can do the same with the
staff
so again the staff is the same imagine
this is
the club side pointed in towards my body
i turn 180 degrees and then throw it out
remember this is on the outside of my
arm i'll bring it back around
and then i can bring it back up again
okay
and then you smooth the movement out
feel the weight of the
the staff drop down i want to feel this
weight drop down
create a circle behind like a circular
pendulum behind my head
and then i let that swing and then
passed out on the inside
okay stop and then reverse the direction
the other way
okay it then comes back i can then
transfer
into the other hand back to the side
back up now we're on the other side
again
the same idea as the with the clubs i
bring it in at this 45 degree angle
throw it out this time it's going across
my body
and i stop at the side and i'll reverse
the direction so i'm casting it
away from my body so it's going outwards
so it comes up
turn my body out
okay so in a routine
you start by going inwards so inwards
one and then outwards change hands
so inwards to start with
stop outwards
change hands inwards
stop outwards change hands
inwards stop outwards
change hands same with the club inwards
stop
outwards change hands inwards
stop outwards change hands
you just can kind of carry on this
pattern
and it just continues in this cycle
as many times as you want to do it
so all these movements that we've done
with the club and the staff
you can do with the sailor and actually
i mean i'm using the saber it could be
any sort
but what it does is it gives you that
blade alignment um
and that teaches you how to use the club
and staff properly
if you think about doing these movements
you want your knuckles on top so when
i'm turning here
as i'm striking down see my knuckles are
on top there i don't want something
strange like this
that'd be like holding your sword and
doing a cup like this
make any sense so you want to make sure
that when you're turning
you're cutting with the blade down
and then that gets your hand in the
right position
so when you're thinking of the weapons
application of this
all these movements are the same with
the sabre
you see is the same movement
with the club all the stuff
you can do it turning between your body
going the other direction
yeah it's all the same thing so again
with the staff you can do these
movements i was showing it holding from
the center
but actually if we move up and down to
here
we can also do these movements
in a more sort of standard grip i would
actually hold this stuff
so if you think of this movement where
we're raising
again i'll show you raising from the
middle but if we've got our hand here we
could raise
to cut obviously now i'm actually
putting footwork in as well
but the movement is still the same
all these sort of movements where we're
raising it up turning
that's why i think this exercise is so
important because it actually teaches
you
um i suppose planes of control that type
of thing
and transitioning whether it's like say
a club staff
sword it's all the same thing
anyway i hope you enjoyed the video
please like share and subscribe
and if you've got any comments i'll be
interested to hear what you thought so
leave them down below
i'll catch you again soon